Maurice jones-drew former NFL running
back NFL Network analyst and mojo back
on the program
Maurice how are you this morning how are
you I'm doing okay
you know the overreaction Monday with
the NFL with week one what what is your
biggest overreaction to what you saw
over the weekend I feel like there was a
lot of teams that we thought were gonna
be better weren't really that good I
guess I can't say that I mean I felt
like Pittsburgh should have blew out
just blown out Cleveland but that didn't
work so Cleveland may be better than
what we thought
right yeah I thought that they played
hard yeah they I don't know if that's an
overreaction I give you over I'm not
gonna give you this is I don't think
this is an overreaction but I think the
Jaguars
have a great chance of winning that ASU
style okay that might be an overreaction
with what you saw that the defense
looked great but I still get concerns
about Blake bortles and you lose Allen
Robinson I like fournette there are some
positives there and that division is bad
but it might be a little bit of an
overreaction there but I like it you're
bringing something to work how about the
Rams you know offens goes for worse the
first offensive juggernaut there how bad
are the cold snow mojo you know what I
don't they have a lot of injuries there
one and two you know Scott Rosine it's
weird in this league that the backup
quarterback for a lot of teams they're
those guys that are they're not to
really mess with the psyche of the
starting quarterback yeah but sometimes
these guys have to play and then they go
out there and you know he made some
really good throws parts of the game but
then he made some really bad ones and
those were the ones that you saw go to
the house or different things like that
and wait if it'll did a good job I just
feel like the Rams they have they've
always had Talent but now they kind of
have a structured way of where they want
to go and how they want to do things and
they're playing well at what point would
you shut down Andrew Luck for the rest
of the season if this let's say this
goes on for
or five more games your Owen 401 five
one in four and Andrew Luck you might
bring him back could you see a scenario
where the Colts would just say you know
what we're not gonna risk this I mean
for me anytime you have a quarterback
that's had a shoulder surgery the same
way Andrew Luck and Cam Newton did and
then he can't be back ready for a week
one after nine was it has it been nine
months since he had surgery I think
eight or nine months you know exactly
yeah yeah I mean that's that's a concern
there so I wouldn't put him out there
because he's supposed to be your
franchise quarterback you you paid him
140 million dollars that you want to
make sure that he's gonna be available
for the future this one year main we
just may have to you know chalk this one
up and and rebuild and try to look to
some different things because you put
him out there and he gets hurt again and
that could be a career ender I was
talking to Tony Dungy and Rodney
Harrison yesterday we're watching the
games at football night in America and
they both expressed concerns about the
lack of participation in preseason games
for the starters and it showed but not
just quarterback or wide receiver
running backs we're talking about you
know the punt team and the long snapper
like everywhere
can you see a scenario where we're gonna
have two preseason games where the
starters do play a lot more and then we
add one or two more regular-season games
is that on the horizon here I don't
think you had more regular-season games
the reason we have to understand that
the way the kind of league is set up now
where the practice is or have to be a
certain way in training camp and and all
these different deals teams are now more
concerned about getting their starters
to week one I mean we saw so many guys
go through training camps some of the
guys not go through training camp and
guys still get hurt right so Eric's
buried his Achilles goes out he went
through training camp I mean you want at
least get I'd rather lose Eric very weak
one then losing week three of the
preseason and so I think it's a fine
line where you want to stay healthy for
week one but you also want to get you're
working in training camp and so coaches
are trying to figure out how to do that
how do how do we play with this fine
line how do we still get our
guys better but also have them ready for
week one because we know in this league
the way the league is you really only
get two three two to three years as the
coach to go out there and start winning
games if you don't win games in two to
three years most likely you're going to
get fired that's the turnover you see
every year the NFL where there's six
jobs GM jobs had coaching jobs that are
open every year Maurice jones-drew NFL
Network analyst former NFL running back
Thursday night NFL net or Texans and the
Bengals watching beastmode run yesterday
I mean you didn't run exactly like him
but you know with Marshawn Lynch
punishes you when you ran the what's
that like that feeling when you know
that you're punishing a defensive player
you know it's funny you say that because
we actually grew up in the same area so
we have to say a similar running style
but obviously he's a bigger version of
what I wasn't league but when you put
your shoulder and you run over at 305
pounder that that has played in a Pro
Bowl level for the last three or four
years you're you're doing some different
and when you run a guy over like that
it's it's a confidence builder for you
obviously in your team and it's a
demoralize URF or for the other team
when he saw him run over jerel Casey I
want to say one of the linebackers got
up and was like yelling at somebody cuz
he was like there's no way he's gonna be
able to do that right and so that's why
that's why Marshawn came back he you
know I got a chance to speak with him a
little bit and you know he wanted to
come back office because Oakland's leave
him but to be that lasting image for the
City of Oakland that's that's starting
to rebuild and trying to regrow and and
do some real good things in the
community with the schools and the
streets they're rebuilding and all those
type of deals so he wanted to be a part
of that and I think he's the missing
piece for this team because that defense
actually played much better now against
the Titans which was we were we were all
shocked that's a-that's I mean if you
want to overreaction there's a Jaguar
the is the Raiders defense gonna play
like this all year and so I think a lot
of that comes from that offense and from
that offenses beastmode mentality as
well did you ever hear like the
and go out of a defensive player when
you run into him the reason I bring this
up drone bet is he could hear guys like
whimper you know when bus would run into
like when you go look at a boxer when
they take a body blow that's what you
hear like well you hit Shawn Merriman
when you declared Shawn Merriman that
was pretty good right houses back side
skipping off the ground did you ever
bring that up to him you know you know
what we're we're adults oh my I bring it
up all the time that's why when I see
them here in LA sometimes we'll go out
to dinner and the world will be at the
same restaurant
I'll get that side I look from them
because of you you never talked about it
huh yeah we try not to talk about it as
much you know just something that we
both understood and now we just go over
moving forward in our lives
we're going to talk about me calling the
Chiefs
over the Patriots or whatever you're
just gonna beat around the bush today I
didn't know you called the Chiefs over
the Patriots oh my goodness you can't
you must not even must not be watching
if our network on 24 hour I mean I watch
it a lot I only watch them when Rich
Eisen Zahn
oh that well that's not he's not on he's
only on Sundays and Thursdays okay legal
people that work at work as well oh
there is I just thought when aizen's on
the NFL Network's on and then it goes
off after that hurts my feelings okay
Gillian give me your call prior to the
Chiefs Patriots let me give you the
stage here I okay so what I said was I
got a lot of flack for it to like
barstool sports a lot of other people
were saying I was concussed and sprays
he I don't know what I'm talking about
he's fired it was crap it was
unbelievable
you know I was concerned I'm sorry I
really felt like people just didn't
really believe my football knowledge
like I haven't been doing this in 77
years old but that's neither here nor
there did you say that Andy Reid what
was gay
the Chiefs are coaching advantage
against Bill Belichick yes that's what I
said okay give me give me the reason for
them okay well this is the first thing
I'll say this I had a coach tell me
because when I first retired I wanted to
go on a case and I had a coach to tell
me you're only good as the players
around you coaches can never win games
but they can lose games I put in players
and bad situation okay I understand that
so I went through the roster and I
looked at the cheese and they have five
all-pro players on there on that roster
they had Eric Berry who off-lead Torres
patellar tendon they had Justin Huston
who's been an all-pro
Marcus Peters has been all-pro Tyreke
hill and then obviously Travis Kelce so
I said okay five all pros on one team
that's the best coach that's it that's a
staff that gets it
that's rare you see that in the league
but then I also remember Andy Reed when
he gets time to prepare he gets very
creative and he finds a way to exploit
some of your your your I guess you say
weak links on the on the on the on the
defense or offensively they figure out
ways to attack and so I was like okay
that's all I'm gonna give Andy Reed dead
so I went to go look at the Patriots
roster and I was trying to figure out
who was gonna be there pass rusher there
and I figured they would move Hightower
to outside linebacker and let him rush
the press because he's done that before
and then defensively had McCourty I know
they've added Stephon Gilmore and they
had Malcom Butler but neither one of
those guys can run step for step with
Tyreke Hill and they were gonna have to
figure out a way to double-team Travis
Kelce so I said okay I don't know I'm
still leaning to the other side I felt
like the Julian element injury was huge
because he's he's kind of a guy when you
look at the West Julian Edelman and
without him Brady's numbers are vastly
different and so I said okay the Bill
Belichick does have Tom Brady the
greatest of all time but he lost his his
guide Julian Edelman and Gronk
I felt like Gronk and Eric bear was
gonna be a wash now you take those two
guys out and then when I look to the
offensive side I really felt like Alex
Smith is his grown throughout the
preseason he's gotten better
and I just said you know what I'm gonna
go with the team that has more players
in there and a creative coach and Andy
Reed I said Andy Reed and I got all this
kind of backlash all right we're gonna
have to go yeah I I can only give you so
much time in the spotlight here guys
could we give a round applause - Maurice
jones-drew
mojo will put you up on a pedestal and
Channel yeah we're gonna do it again
soon when you make another great
prediction like that okay I somebody's
probably up in the next 70 years I'm
gonna hold on to this one for a while
Thank You mojo I appreciate it that's
later that's Maurice jones-drew
NFL Network analyst and great
prognosticator the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience